katarina you won the first two games but
it's been four draws since then
you're feeling you you took the lead
after
other players backed up but they seem to
be catching you you can't seem to get
that win to separate yourself what's
going on this is really hard it's hard
to win a game and despite making draws i
think all draws were like fight you know
it wasn't like a berlin wall or
something and game over uh i think every
single game that finished in a draw it
was just it was a long fight and i think
i had chances in many of those games but
opponent just played really well
so at the stage you're in right now
you're in a three-way tie for first with
uh ashrita joining you and karissa
joining you once again
your estimation about this at the exact
midpoint of the tournament
i don't really think about the standings
i'm very happy the way i'm playing so
far i think i could speed up a little
bit and play faster but so far i think
it's it's going well and i'm glad
all right well we'll let you go with
that and keep playing well thank you
absolutely keep